I want to start with thank you for
making me laugh like a crazy person I
appreciate it yay that was one of the
goals
and you did it
um but before we get into cocaine bear
which I love saying the title
um if someone has actually never seen
anything that you've acted in before
what is the first thing you'd like them
watching and why wow um I think Effie
Trinket in The Hunger Games because I
just I love the journey that she makes
especially in Catching Fire I would
watch the second one Catching Fire
because she really
um for me I think really goes on an
incredible journey and she looks good
doing it those costumes were very good
yeah this is one of those projects that
I really can't believe got made the
title I can't believe was approved I
can't believe the MPAA let this happen
so what was there anything like that
actually
um almost derailed this you know someone
saying we can't make this you know the
only thing that could have derailed it
frankly was if we didn't believe
um that wedda could deliver the bear
because everything else was about out
being bold it was about being audacious
it was about you know challenging people
to uh create something that lived up to
the title cocaine Bear right and to me
the biggest risk of the entire Endeavor
was I I had no I had no lead character
like the bear was never going to be
there and it had to work it had to be
real it had to be like Photo realistic
documentary of a bear in the woods
um and I I you know I I didn't know if
if it was going to work out and of
course I had great Partners in wetta
wetta delivered the most beautiful bear
I could imagine and an incredible
performance for that bear you know with
the collaboration was just a dream and
um it it it
it's the only way the movie works is if
the bear works what it does do
incredible work and with the challenges
of the VFX industry it's great you had a
great partner like that they were
excited to do it they're used to doing
you know like superheroes flying through
space and time and warps and I don't you
know this was like old school like can
you make this bear look like I want
people to ask me if there was a real
bear on set like that's how real it has
to be and I I really think they they did
it there are some fantastic kills in
this movie that are bloody as
um beep and um just stuff that made me
very I was very much enjoying it
watching it in the theater did you
actually have a favorite of the kills or
one that you are really excited for
audiences to see I don't I hate giving
things away
um but I will say this I I wanted to
make sure the audience remained
surprised and I did not think that the
bear should kill everybody I felt that
the humans the the hubris of the humans
um is really the villainy in the picture
right it's about like humans thinking
they can control nature and humans their
level of greed you know and like their
their um their sense of superiority and
it's like that's what the villainy was
so anytime we could play with somebody's
um bad instincts and turn it and and
murder someone because of it that those
were the surprising ones that made me
the most happy what was it actually like
showing it to the MPAA for the first
time and did they actually ask you to
pull back on anything no it was R-rated
from jump I mean they didn't ask us to
do anything we I was honestly I was
never worried about the gore or the
blood or the kills or the action because
you know that's in many many other
R-rated movies I was worried about the
kids like what were they you know the
kids doing
um you know being with the drugs and um
but at the end of the day everybody was
okay with it I mean I mean you know it's
R-rated it's for adults but
um I didn't have to I did not have to
make any sacrifices for the movie
everything that I hoped would be in the
film is in the film how did I'm
fascinated by the editing process
because that's where it all comes
together so how did the film possibly
change in the editing room in ways you
didn't expect you know honestly it's
that I had to give up so much amazing
stuff with these actors you know I mean
the the original introduction of
Carrie's character she was singing in
her kitchen
um this Mama's and Papa's song and she
was so nervous about singing she's never
sang on camera before and she had done
this incredible work and it's not in the
movie so to me
the worst part about the edit was all
the amazing stuff that ended up on The
Cutting Room floor that said my goal was
to tell this story in 95 minutes you
know I just think this concept it should
be done efficiently it should be fun it
should be wild and then you should go
have a drink after and talk about it
with your friends I won't lie when I
found out the run time I was like oh
this is a this is perfect yeah
it's this movie doesn't need more time
than it than it took you know so I that
that that's what I mean by the editing
the script actually was had a lot more
character development it was really
beautiful but at the end of the day
people want to see a bear on cocaine
killing people so that's what we did oh
no 100 that 100
um you have a joke in the movie four
Pines uh Mall which is a little nod to
Back to the Future can you talk about
that we had we have those kinds of nods
all over little little Easter eggs
throughout the movie that that was one
of them thank you for picking that up
um we you know we also for instance like
when you meet DD in her bedroom there's
a poster of Madonna I was a 12 year old
girl in 1985 so I very much related with
Dede she basically is like had my room I
had that papasan chair you know that
everybody had with the like afghan
blanket that your grandma knit for you
um but more importantly she's obsessed
with Madonna which I was also there's a
poster of Madonna on her wall wearing
black overalls and a white T-shirt and
and the rubber bracelets and then
Brooklyn wears that outfit throughout
the movie so it's little things like
that you know Jane the the opening song
was an homage to what had American
Summer yeah I didn't realize that but
yes that I um uh was it tough not was it
did you have uh with Isaiah in the movie
you have the whole you know sheet
um can you how much debate was there
with that because it's an iconic line
that he you know was famous for we did
debate it he did do it on that he loves
doing it it's his favorite thing to do
uh but at the end of the day the thing
that got the biggest reaction
um was him on the roof making those
noises when he can't climb down you know
they're like
like he the entire crew fell out
laughing I mean we I couldn't call cut
it was so enjoyable watching him do that
and while he was when it was happening I
thought to myself this is going to be in
the movie and it is last thing for you
do you know what you're actually going
to direct next are you looking at
scripts I'm always looking sure I mean
you never know you know you never know
when something's gonna pop up I mean
this came truly out of nowhere
um and so I am always looking but I
don't I don't know what I'm going to do
I'm gonna take a really long nap Steve
I'm gonna nap for like three weeks after
this comes out hopefully
um that note I have to stop I'm just
gonna say I really hope it's a huge hit
for you and um I really did laugh a lot
watching it great thank you I'm glad you
enjoyed the ride